I don't like about it we expect them now  to do something they go there to play  football so the big tournament was  organized and planned by other people  and that's not that's the thing and if  you don't like it say it but not now  when the tournament is happening when  the players have to play the games and  want to play the games a big tournament  and all the rest is for really other  people making decisions and we say in  Germany  um somebody Cooks the soup and the other  one have to take it out so and equip  that the soup got cooked  more than 10 years ago and now these  these boys they were 10 years old when  the decisions were made and now they  should be in any kind of situation where  they could be criticized for no way  there's too much pressure on them to be  Advocates that's what you what you do in  a moment if you ask me that question for  me it's no problem but you ask them the  question yes then you put pressure on  them and that's not fair